republican senator roger markle who
represents kansas joins us now
um it's it's terrible damage especially
in in towns like andover
um but it could have been worse you're
right john it could have been a lot
worse thank goodness for the national
weather service local tv stations radio
local preparedness people who got people
through this a thousand homes were
pretty much destroyed friday night today
those folks are waking up picking up the
pieces i've been through this too often
with other communities trying to find
that picture that would use treasures so
much some mementos especially want to
shout out to those kids at prairie creek
elementary who lost their school and
just reassure them that their parents
the local school officials are working
for a place for them to finish up grade
school this semester yeah there's some
of the footage on the screen right now i
mean that is just a terrifying sight
when you see that thing coming i suppose
it's it's worse when it's coming at you
in the night time and you can't see
exactly where it's going but that is
just a frightening picture right there
yes sir it sure is they sound like a
tornado coming at you again i've seen
too many of them thank goodness nobody
was killed yeah there were those three
university of oklahoma students who were
who were up in kansas
working on the uh the the storm they
were meteorology students and they were
killed in a traffic accident trying to
go home that's just
the worst kind of thing so so tragic
well uh our you know prayers and
thoughts are with the people of kansas
as they rebuild but again um you can
rebuild buildings you can't rebuild
lives
let's talk about the the border crisis
um
you are particularly incensed at what's
going on regarding the fentanyl
that's flooding across the southern
border talk about that for a moment well
look this kansas is no longer a border
state this problem this crisis has been
brought to kansas just this past week i
learned of a boy that i delivered i'm an
obstetrician and delivered him 15 years
ago died probably from percocet laced
with fentanyl two young students boys
from kansas city area died 2500 kansans
overdosed in the past three months over
six tons of fentanyl have been
apprehended at the border since
president biden took office it's truly a
crisis and the sad thing is it looks
like this administration wants this
crisis and six tons apprehended we have
no idea how much has gotten through
that's right so talking to the border
patrol there i've been there three times
now looking uh forward to a fourth trip
on may 23rd because that's when title 42
ends but the border patrol tells me for
every every ounce they catch maybe two
or three more ounces get through un
undetected let's look at some of the
numbers from the del rio sector that's
one of the busiest sector uh for border
crossings along the southern border in
2021 uh 68 000 and change came across
there 2022 195
289 and again those are the
apprehensions that doesn't count the
number that you know got aways um that's
185
increase in numbers senator yeah john i
want to begin bring this home to kansas
kansas a population of 3 million people
at least 3 million people have been
apprehended since joe biden was sworn in
and again to your prop to your point
probably two to three times more than
that have been leaked through and then
finally as we get through may 23rd if
title 42 is taken away from us those
numbers will double again but you know
the the homeland security secretary says
hey if if we find these people if if we
catch them and they're not entitled to
stay in our country they're going back
how do you answer that well i i just
don't see that happening they haven't
been able to handle this number of
people and those numbers are going to
double and triple and again just think
about what the cartel is doing they're
using these human shields to smuggle in
uh narcotics and then they throw a kid
out about the boat when the when they're
about to get busted and then they make
the escape so there's no way that we
have the ability to handle two to three
times the amount of
crossings we have right now they're
thinking about making our veterans
hospitals shortchanged by taking doctors
and nurses from there and sitting to the
border we already have a problem with
the waiting times already with the va
hospitals yeah uh secretary mayorkis was
on the
morning shows this morning and one of
the things he said is hey we've we're
getting the message out do not come do
not come to our border
how are they getting that message out
senator well certainly that's not the
message people are hearing across the
world i think president biden has been
loud and clear saying come bring us
everybody we're here for you and when
you get here you're going to get free
health care free food and water so
they're you know they're treated better
than our veterans are but they're
treated better than our soldiers are so
here's my orcas today but for over a
year now this president has been saying
come everybody you're welcome the gates
are wide open
we had a report top of the hour about
how secretary i'm sorry how speaker
nancy pelosi took a democrat
uh
delegation to keeve to meet with
president vladimir zolensky
i i was curious why no republicans would
this not have been a good time to do a
bipartisan trip you know it sure would
have been and i assume that nobody was
invited but here's the question was this
just all show or is this administration
going to finally come through with some
serious sanctions all you have to do is
look at the value of the ruble the value
of the ruble is now above what it was
pre-war so the sanctions are not working
this white house has dragged their feet
and implementing them even a lot of the
energy sanctions on uh the the the banks
in russia have not been implemented yet
so we're hoping it's not all show that
there'll be some go there for this
administration i want to play very
quickly something from your republican
colleague in the house victoria sparts
she is a ukrainian she was born in
ukraine now serves in the congress
listen
if you look about from last package you
know 13.6 billion package only 3.5
actually went to military aid and not
all to ukraine you know we need to ask
questions what happened with the rest
i'll be honest with you i've been in
poland twice i've been in ukraine twice
now and i haven't seen evidence of a lot
of this humanitarian assistance so i
would like to ask this question she's
saying that about 10 billion dollars
from the last package that was you know
supposedly dispensed to ukraine didn't
get there where is it going you know
that's a great question john i was in
poland fairly recently and i think
that's the same challenges it was easy
to get
items to the border but then get them
past the border there are lots of supply
chain disruptions that's going to
continue to be to be the challenge and
again we hope this administration is
ready to engage now it's day 67 we're
the leader of the free world it's time
we start acting like it all right so
you're not one of those who says that
the europeans ought to be doing more
oh europeans absolutely need to be doing
more they should be leading on this and
i've been saying that since the
beginning we don't want this to be
russia versus america we need the
european union to be leading they have
the financial whereabouts to do it they
need to be leading as well all right
congress
i'm sorry
senator
roger marshall from kansas republican
it's good to have you in john thank you
enjoy your stay in new york great to be
here thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else